pablo tiene la opción entre un plan de
seguro médico con alto deducible o uno
con bajo con un bajo deducible y cuando
hablamos del deducible en un seguro
médico si alguien dice que tiene un plan
con mil dólares de deducible esto
significa que la compañía de seguros
solo paga el costo de los gastos médicos
cuando se rebasa el valor del deducible
entonces si tienes un deducible médico
de mil dólares incurre en un gasto
médico de 800 dólares tú vas a pagar
esos 800 dólares la compañía de seguros
no te va a pagar nada pero si tu
deducible es de mil dólares y tu gasto
médico total es de 1200 dólares tú vas a
tener que pagar los primeros mil y
después la compañía va a pagar el resto
entonces con esto en mente
pensemos acerca de estos dos planes
si pablo escoge el plan de bajo
deducible él tendrá que pagar los
primeros
dólares de cualquier costo médico el
plan de deducible bajo cuesta ocho mil
dólares al año en esta situación él
tendrá que pagar ocho mil dólares para
obtener el seguro si él tiene gastos
médicos de 800 dólares la compañía no
los paga si tiene dos mil dólares en
gastos médicos entonces él paga los
primeros mil y la compañía paga a los
segundos mil si él gasta diez mil
dólares en gastos médicos él paga los
primeros mil y la compañía paga los
nueve mil restantes
si pablo decide el plan de alto
deducible él pagará los primeros dos mil
quinientos dólares de cualquier costo
médico el costo del plan con alto
deducible cuesta siete mil quinientos al
año
y tiene sentido que el plan de alto
deducible cueste menos que el plan de
bajo deducible ya que aquí la compañía
de seguros no entra hasta que tenga un
gasto mayor a los 2500 dólares mientras
que aquí sólo son 1000 para poder tomar
una decisión correcta
pablo encontró estadísticas acerca de
problemas comunes de salud que sufre
gente similar a él asuma que la tabla
abajo en este caso la puse aquí a mi
derecha muestra las probabilidades
correctas y los costos totales de la
atención médica durante el siguiente año
entonces esta tabla de aquí está
diciendo cuál es la probabilidad que no
tenga gastos médicos cuál es la
probabilidad tiene un 25 por ciento de
probabilidades 10.000 dólares 20 por
ciento de cuatro mil dólares y esta es
una simplificación una gran
simplificación del mundo real porque en
el mundo real
esto hace sonar que sólo hay cinco
posibles costos médicos que alguien
puede tener
mil 4000 7.000 y 15.000 en el mundo real
uno puede tener 20 dólares de costos
médicos o 20.000 puedes tener 999
dólares en el mundo real tenemos muchas
muchas más situaciones que deberíamos de
acomodar en la tabla pero dicho esto
esta no es una mala aproximación
si quieres construir esto no es difícil
hacer los cálculos que probablemente los
autores hicieron 30 por ciento 0 25 %
1000 esto es puramente indicativo si
tuvieras que agrupar todos los costos
posibles en conjuntos más grandes
es probablemente un buen método para
encontrar qué tipo de seguro médico a
alguien le conviene comprar entonces
incluyendo el costo del seguro cuál es
el costo médico total que se puede
esperar que pablo pague con el plan de
bajo deducible redondela respuesta en
centavos
sacaré la calculadora para esto entonces
con el seguro de póliza barata el seguro
de póliza barata
con el seguro de póliza barata él tendrá
que pagar su costo será de 8 mil sin
importar qué pase él va a pagar 8 mil
sin importar qué pase eso es ocho mil
dólares entonces veamos hay un 30 por
ciento de probabilidades de que él no
pague nada entonces será más punto 3 x 0
y lo escribo para que vean que lo toma
en consideración y después hay un 25 por
ciento de posibilidades de que tenga mil
dólares de costos médicos y en el plan
de bajo deducible él aún tiene que pagar
esos mil dólares entonces más punto 25
de probabilidades de qué
y él pague
dólares mil dólares y entonces uno dirá
más puntos veinte por cuatro mil pero
recuerden si sus costos médicos son 4000
él no va a pagar 4 mil él sólo pagará
los primeros mil entonces es más punto 2
en esta situación él sólo tiene que
pagar mil dólares la compañía de seguros
pagará pagar a los siguientes tres mil
entonces punto dos x
miel después más más punto 2 20% de
probabilidades inclusive cuando sus
costos médicos sean de 7000 él sólo
tendrá que pagar los primeros mil
tenemos
punto 2 x
otra vez y ahora más punto 0 5 por mil
si él gasta 15 mil
él sólo tendrá que pagar los primeros
mil x
y obtenemos 8 mil 700 dólares y una
manera en la que podemos ver eso es ok
tendrá que pagar 8
mil ocho mil dólares sin importar que
pase y en cualquiera de las situaciones
en las que se encuentre que tenga que
pagar son estas cuatro situaciones que
se encuentran aquí hay un 70 por ciento
de probabilidades de caer en alguna de
estas situaciones y en cualquiera de
estas sólo tendrá que pagar mil dólares
la compañía de seguros pagará el resto
entonces podemos decir ocho mil más hay
un 70 por ciento de probabilidades de
que él pague 1000
una vez más esta tabla es una gran
simplificación del mundo real
probablemente hayan muchos escenarios
donde tendrá que pagar 100 dólares o 600
dólares o lo que sea pero ahorita vamos
a ver solo esto es una simplificación
hay un 70% de probabilidades de que
tenga que pagar mil dólares entonces
esos son 700 dólares más los 8 mil
dólares de seguro nos dan 8 mil 700
dólares entonces entonces escribamos eso
8 mil
cientos
dólares
incluyendo el costo del seguro cuál es
el costo total esperado para pablo con
el plan de alto deducible de donde su
respuesta en centavos entonces veamos el
plan de alto deducible va a tener que
pagar 7500 sin importar que pase
7500 sin importar que pase y después hay
un ser
podemos escribir 0 dólares por 30 por
ciento o 30% por 0 lo que será 0
y un 25 por ciento de probabilidades que
gaste mil dólares entonces más punto 25
x
mil hay un 20% de probabilidades más
puntos 2 no va a pagar 4 mil va a pagar
los primeros 2000
500 entonces hay un 20% de
probabilidades de que gaste 2500 por
2500 y la compañía de seguros pagará a
los otros 1500 más otro 20% de
probabilidades
inclusive en esta situación él sólo
tendrá que pagar dos mil quinientos por
dos mil
502.500 y finalmente
hay un 5 por ciento de probabilidades
inclusive en esta situación él solo
tiene que pagar los primeros 2500 por
2 nos da
ocho mil 875 dólares entonces ocho mil
75 dólares entonces otra vez lo podemos
ver como que hay un 25% de
probabilidades de que paguen 1000
dólares y después tenemos un 45 por
ciento de probabilidades de que pague
2500 dólares en todas estas situaciones
él está pagando 2500 dólares
pero de cualquier manera él paga ocho
mil 875 dólares si pablo quiere el menor
costo a largo plazo y tiene que pagar a
alguno de los dos seguros él debería de
comprar el costo esperado total del
seguro junto con los gastos médicos es
menor en el plan de bajo deducible de
impuestos entonces este de aquí es el
plan de bajo
d
y una vez más no se deberían de usar
estos vídeos como recomendaciones de qué
tipo de deducible tienes que comprar
pero también es una manera interesante
de verlo típicamente bueno no
directamente el plan de bajo deducible a
la larga va a la larga va bueno no
siempre el plan de bajo deducible será
un mejor trato pero al menos en esta
situación el plan de bajo deducible
parece ser el más conveniente tiene un
costo total esperado más bajo dadas
estas probabilidades